i very much for most of my career have  had the yes virus and as somebody who  gets much more uh satisfaction out of  helping others than myself it's very  hard to say no and it feels selfish to  say no but what i'm realizing as i'm  getting older is the gray hairs start  coming in  um i've been able to accomplish a lot  more by saying no more often first of  all the big eye opener to me is how many  people actually respect you saying no  coming up front and saying hey listen  i've got you know vaynermedia to build  we're up to 120 employees we're at 25 i  would have never been able to get to  this place in the last year if i kept  saying yes to everything